Peter Gilroy Raja Garcia the third and
we're here for Boehner police Wow yes
okay that big was a little curveball yes
the big one how sure you haven't gotten
Boehner please yet it's about an
overpopulated future and there's a
sexual prohibition it's there for sex
it's basically it's basically minority
report but change everything to bonus
yes it's not funny at all yes there's a
lot of dildo shopping and strap on some
questions and number one number one gap
well it started as just a little comedy
short and we used sausages and and we
used a lot of things but when we did the
big budget thing and we knew we had to
go for strap ons and really happy and
your friends we recommend the pleasure
they have lots of candy by the different
shades I be sure it's I kind of really
want to make sure it's like a real is
we're feeling get a purple dick if you
want
Wow yeah I feel Twitter's great I mean
we're stand-up comedians and music has
kind of to test out our material it's
like whatever jokes to think about it's
classier than writing it down that I
guess writing it down so 2000 else
happens next follow some funny people
iphone in all ways I did stand-up last
night I just talked about my dad getting
a divorce and making me tape tape news
nasheman video just talked about it for
30 minutes
yeah is that what Jenny McCarthy no yes
almost back to boners you almost got
full circle shopping for that's personal
like i'm using the harm or just the
whole I think you've just got to make
something you like because you know by
the end there you're working
twenty-four/seven on it and you're going
to get burnt out unless you really love
markets owners and the owner police and
just you know you got have a good story
we had a lot of fun it was just like you
know being back in college with all my
friends thank you
Oh